[Musik]
wie werden wir in zukunft leben arbeiten
wohnen das lässt sich nur schwer
vorhersagen obwohl bei der prognose wo
die meisten von uns leben werden sind
sich eigentlich alle experten einig in
städten
sie sind der lebensraum der zukunft im
jahre 2050 werden wohl um die 70 prozent
der weltbevölkerung in städten leben
die herausforderungen bezahlbarer
wohnraum anpassungen an
klimaveränderungen nachhaltige mobilität
digitalisierung energieversorgung viele
baustellen in der stadt der zukunft
eine stadt für die zukunft bauen das hat
man auch in heilbronn versucht auf dem
gelände der bundesgartenschau
die soll aber keine smart city werden
hier geht es nicht nur um high tech und
effiziente infrastruktur im neuen
stadtteil am neckar geht es vor allem um
lebensqualität um möglichst viel grün
trotz dichter bebauung kurze wege und
bezahlbare mieten
wie kann die stadt zukunftsfähig
gestaltet werden ein komplexes thema
stichpunkte sind hier mobilität energie
vernetzung und eine weitere wichtige
frage können städte immer weiter wachsen
ein paar vision die zukunft gehört den
metropolen schon heute leben die meisten
menschen weltweit in großen städtischen
ballungszentren ein trend der auch
weiter anhalten wird so werden wir
morgen leben sagt eine die es wissen
muss
kristin ring ist architektur professorin
war leiterin des deutschen architektur
zentrums und lehrt heute in den usa die
amerikanerin ist auch überzeugt stadt
immer weiter in der fläche aus zypern
werden die städte in den nächsten
jahrzehnten fast unweigerlich in die
höhe wachsen müssen die stadt der kurzen
wege ist eigentlich das ziel dass wenn
man aus der haustür geht dass man alles
innerhalb von fünf minuten zehn minuten
reichte also laufweg hat und daher wenn
man mehr menschen auf einen auf eine
fläche unterbringen möchte dann muss es
auch in der höhe gehen vernetzte
individuell von bewohnern gestaltete
innenstadt häuser mit modernen
etagenwohnungen wie hier in berlin wird
es künftig immer mehr geben sagt kristin
ring voraus hinzu kommt ihren
energiebedarf werden viele der neuen
häuser dabei selbst decken aus sonne
wind oder eigenen kleinkraftwerken
überschüssige energie geben sie an
gebäude ab die noch keine
selbstversorger sind
eigentlich mit die deutschen
baustandards von heute plus alle diese
dieser anderer kleinteilige
energieversorgung kann man mehr
produzieren als man braucht dass es eine
sogenannte energie plus haus und damit
kann man wenn man die stadt auch
insgesamt betrachtet sieht man eine
balance zwischen die neue häuser die
mehr produzieren und die alte häuser die
natürlich ein bisschen mehr energie
brauchen statt verkehrschaos und
verstopfter straßen wird es in der stadt
der zukunft mehr fahrräder busse und
bahnen geben glaubt architekten ring
öffentliche elektromobile könnten
privatautos ersetzen
ihre vision den strom beziehen die
elektro taxis kontaktlos aus gebäuden an
denen sie gerade vorbeikommen oder
während der fahrt aus induktions feldern
in der straße das ziel eine stadt ohne
parkende autos stellen sie sich vor wenn
keine autos mehr parken auf der straße
dann hat man eigentlich komplett andere
flächen man hat auch komplett also mit
nur elektrofahrzeuge hat man auch ganz
anderes geräuschpegel da kann man auch
ganz anderer flächen bebauen
zum beispiel neben der autobahn und rené
nähe von von größere straßen so heißen
die wichtigsten themen im künftigen
stadtleben mobilität energieversorgung
und vernetzung faktoren einer
vorausschauenden stadtplanung die alle
drei fest im blick behalten muss die
stadt der zukunft muss für mich den
menschen wieder in den fokus nehmen
technologie muss im einklang und
vorbildern natur sein und dadurch
entsteht eine lebenswerte stadt die
zukunft gestalten das will oliver
zöllner verantwortlich für die
gesamtplanung des bundesgartenschau
geländes in heilbronn
die ausstellung ist die erste
kombination ausgaben und stadt
ausstellung
zöllner hat noch viel vor sich und
seinen zeitplan ist straff
denn es wird weitergebaut bis 2027 soll
im neckar bogen eine stadtlandschaft
entstehen ich hab so ein bisschen das
gefühl da wo die stadt ausstellung
stattfindet das ist schon so ein
bisschen das ist das filetstück der
stadt oder ja es war eigentlich eine
kaputte bahnbrache hier war
infrastruktur nördlich der bahn war bahn
logistik und eigentlich was ein weißer
fleck mitten in der stadt
ok und wie haben sie den jetzt werfe
bekommen dass man da jetzt nicht nur die
bundesgartenschau stattfinden lassen
kann sondern auch noch sozusagen ganzen
kiez hochziehen
ja es war schon eine grundentscheidung
der stadt natürlich zu sagen man baut
nicht an den rändern wir sehen ja auch
nur das innenstadt modell heilbronn
125.000 einwohner heißt eine kleine
großstadt aber natürlich potenzial für
urbanität und die idee war letztendlich
dieses areal komplett von der bahn zu
erwerben eine jahrhundertaufgabe um dann
mitten in der stadt bani tät wachsen zu
lassen nämlich auch mit städtischen
strukturen so will man im neunzehnten
jahrhundert die bahnhofsvorstadt am
bahnhof gebaut hat wieder ein neues
stadtquartier auf der gegenseite der
bahn hier entstehen zu lassen
gut jetzt hatten sie ja auch viele
investoren viele bauträger die sich da
zusammen getan haben und es ist ja auch
so ein riesen großes gebiet
was war denn eigens für die größte
schwierigkeit etwas von seiner dimension
sozusagen mitten in der stadt hoch zu
ziehen
ja natürlich liegt oder so eine
bahnareal 100 jahre industriegeschichte
und heilbronn ist im jahr 1944 fast
vollständig zerstört worden
das heißt wir haben hier erstmal
altlasten saniert wir haben kampfmittel
räumen wir haben sprengungen vor ort
gehabt und erst mal aus einem kaputten
areal wieder ein neues stück stadtboden
zu machen das war sicherlich die größte
herausforderung
300 tonnen schrott und 13 tonnen
kampfmittel ausgegraben hunderte bäume
eingepflanzt zwei seen angelegt das ziel
ein kompletter stadtteil für 3500
menschen mit 1000 arbeitsplätzen mitten
in heilbronn am bau beteiligt sind 19
architekten und insgesamt 15 investoren
ihre aufgabe nachhaltig bauen mit neuen
wohnkonzepten eine stadt der kurzen wege
dies wird schon geprobt auf dem gelände
der bundesgartenschau leben schon 500
menschen
das haben wir hier die modelle von dem
23 gebäuden die schon in der
bundesgartenschau stehen was mir jetzt
als erstes auffällt ist die
unterschiedlichkeit der gebäude also
dass er schon kein einheitsbrei kann
sagen wie ist das zu stande gekommen wir
uns geschafft das ganze dann doch so
bunt zu gestalten
ja es sind zwei prinzipien das eine ist
eine einheit zu erzeugen das heißt wir
sehen hier drei blöcke trotzdem eine
vielfalt drin das heißt architekten
durften maximal zwei gebäude planen die
duften aber nicht nebeneinander liegen
es heißt ja erstmal eine vielfalt von
architektur die hier auftritt innerhalb
einer bundesgartenschau
häuser bauen zu dürfen ist
wahrscheinlich versteht dass jeder
architekt ist so eine art spielwiese und
kann sich richtig austoben
was sind denn jetzt hier bei den
gebäuden ihre persönlichen highlights
was natürlich deutlich heraussticht ist
das holz hochhaus was man natürlich in
der ausstellung erst mal lesen muss denn
dieses ist mit aluminium gedeckt aber
trotzdem reißt es jetzt mal die hochhaus
grenze also wirklich konstruktiven
holzbau die hoch aus linie zu erreichen
viele themen zum brandschutz waren zu
klären
ein anderes konzept was hier für die
stadt ausstellung für das stadtquartier
sehr wichtig war
war ja auch so der soziale zusammenhalt
die man gerne fördern sollte welche
projekte gibt es denn da in dieser
stress hat natürlich viel auch mit
bodenordnung fragen zu tun
wir hatten hier von der stadt her die
vorgabe dass dieses grundstück einen
festpreis bekommen also und nicht der
beste preis erzählt und dass es auch
noch abschläge gab für soziale nutzung
also es ging darum dieses zu fördern
dass die vielfalt des miteinanders und
gerade der mittelblock hier haben wir
inklusion zu wohnen drin aber auch
inklusions arbeiten
nebendran eine baugruppe also menschen
die sich selber ein architekt zusammen
statt haus bauen aber auch wie gesagt
viele modelle auch dass studenten wohnen
des geförderten mietwohnungsbau aus
trennen sollte ein abbild ja unsere idee
einer europäischen stadt auf heilbronner
maßstab sein
verdichtete bauweise oder anders
ausgedrückt viele wohnungen auf wenig
raum so schafft man mehr platz für
grünflächen oder sehen gutes klima wurde
hier mit eingeplant direkt am neckar in
einer bundesgartenschau das neue
stadtquartier hier hat keine großen
probleme mit der hitze des sommers
andere großstädte dagegen schon denn
stahl glas beton speichern die wärme und
die frischluftzufuhr funktioniert auch
nicht immer richtig
deshalb ist es in manchen städten auch
acht bis zehn grad wärmer als auf dem
land stadtplaner und architekten suchen
nach lösungen um sich auf den
klimawandel einzustellen
36 grad und es wurde noch heißer immer
dichter höher kompakter wird die stadt
ein enormer druck lastet auf berlin jede
lücke wird geschlossen mit viel glas
stahl und beton
das macht die geforderte hitze speichern
meint markus becker mit dem klimawandel
muss man umdenken
die glasfassaden sind wärmetechnisch
sehr schwer in griff zu kriegen
dahinter ist es brütend warm und ich
denke der in zukunft wird man auch oft
wieder zu lochfassade übergehen müssen
wo die fenster wesentlich kleiner sind
zurück zum ziegelstein baum mehr balkone
die verscharrten helle fassaden die
sonnenstrahlen reflektieren
anstatt dunkle die sie noch speichern
bei tropischen temperaturen werden
trinkbrunnen immer wichtiger berlin will
100 neu aufstellen
finanziert aus dem aktuellen energie und
klimaschutzprogramm fast 100 millionen
euro für eine hitze angepasste statt mit
dem ziel das man verschattet dass man
durchlüftet dass man verdunstungskälte
erzeugt und verdunstungskälte erzeugt
man auf entsiegelt werden und auf
begrünten fassaden und dächern firmen
gärten sind erneuert rennt die terrasse
ein grauer beton nun grüne wohlfühloase
der mitarbeiter
grünen und zum beispiel so schöne
sonnenblumen hier umgeben das entspannt
einfach viel besser und man ist
natürlich viel viel motivierter und kann
sich auch viel viel besser konzentrieren
18.000 dächer sind schon gepflanzt aber
das sind erst 3 prozent auch die blaue
infrastruktur hat noch potenzial
die gewässer sind enorme sauerstoff
speicher bieten lebensqualität wenn sie
denn sauber gehalten werden
diese offenen unbebauten naturräume
leiten frischen wind in die metropole
weil sie als frischluftschneisen dienen
weil es dazu beiträgt die stadt zu
kühlen und umso wichtiger ist für uns
den zugang zum wasser auch nicht zu
verbauen und auch den berlinerinnen und
berlinern offen zu halten
immer mehr menschen fliehen aus dem
heißen beton der metropolen suche nach
neuen sozialen und kulturellen
ankerplätzen flöße als räume zum
austausch da ist noch vieles möglich
meint johannes heereman städte wie
antwerpen oder london machten es vor
seine hoffnung für die zukunft
städtischen gewässer eben nicht nur als
wasserstraßen sondern als öffentlicher
raum als naherholungsfläche für
schwimmen für kunst kultur für alles
mögliche anerkannt werden noch gibt es
nur wenige hausboote auf den berliner
gewässern kaum bezahlbare liegeplätze zu
wenig visionen die stadt braucht noch
viele kluge konzepte um den klimawandel
zu begegnen
eine stadt der zukunft braucht neue
ideen für die energieversorgung am
neckar bogen in heilbronn will man vor
allem die kraft der sonne nutzen
ein beispiel das aktiv plus haus mit
sonnenkollektoren auf dem dach und an
der fassade das gebäude produziert im
jahr mehr energie als seine bewohner für
heizung warmes wasser und strom
benötigen
beim thema nachhaltigkeit steht dieses
gebäude besonders heraus 34 meter hoch
zehn stockwerke
man sieht nicht direkt dass man vor dem
größten holz hochhaus deutschlands steht
die fassade ist mit aluminium platten
verkleidet die stockwerke aus sperrholz
sitzen auf einem sockel aus stahlbeton
wenn man das bauen in der zukunft denkt
dann könnte holz als baustoff eine
ziemlich große rolle spielen denn
immerhin ist holz ein nachwachsender
rohstoff
das hier ist jetzt das modell von dem
größten holz hochhaus deutschlands
verbuchte was es woanders kann man so
ein gebäude aus holz baut als aus den
üblichen materialien wie zum beispiel
tom sind zwei faktoren vor allen dingen
zu nennen zum einen der planungsprozess
der ist deutlich aufwendiger gerade im
höchsten holzer aus deutschland dass wir
hier realisiert haben zuallererst haben
wir uns im experimentellen bauen auch
gefunden haben uns mit brandschutz
themen intensiv auseinandersetzen müssen
wie der schallschutz thematik mit
verschiedenen rahmenbedingungen
baulichen lösungen die wir einfach jetzt
hier im prozess erarbeitet haben und das
zweite ist natürlich die schnelligkeit
wir haben hier ungefähr ein geschoss pro
woche erstellt ausgenommen des
stahlbeton der natürlich auch noch im
haus verbaut wurde aber im rhein holzbau
innerhalb einer woche ein geschoss zu
erstellen das natürlich ganz besonders
und mit der konventionellen bauweise
nicht vergleichbar das heißt wie kann
man so etwas schaffen das wird dann als
modul angeliefert oder wie läuft es
genau
im prinzip ist alles vorgefertigt vorab
genau definiert wird dann in der
in der produktion maßgenau geliefert
kommt dann auch in der richtigen
reihenfolge auf die baustelle wird vom
kran gehoben wie ein großes puzzle in 3d
puzzle zusammengesetzt und auf der
baustelle daneben installiert wenn ich
das jetzt aber vergleiche auch mit einem
betonbau der bekanntermaßen relativ
schädlich ist für die umwelt sehr viel
rohstoffe verwendet werden sehr viel
sand beispielsweise verbraucht wird wie
viel nachhaltiger ist dann der bau mit
holz also rein auf stahlbeton auch rein
auf sand konnten wir zum beispiel auch
nicht verzichten im stahlbeton haben wir
das natürlich verbaut aber ansonsten
haben wir hier 1500 tonnen fichten
tannen verbaut entspricht auch ungefähr
in der lebensdauer 1500 tonnen co2 die
wir gefunden haben mit diesem know hows
und neben den nachhaltigkeitsaspekten
dass die umwelt angeht ist auch die
nachhaltigkeit des wohnens gegeben die
trockenheit ist sehr hoch in gebäudes
wohnklima ist sehr angenehm
bei einem holzhaus fragt sich glaube ich
jeder der dort einzieht was tun wenn's
brennt also sprich wie sicher bin ich in
einem holzhaus gesichert gegen feuer
also hier ist er sicher insbesondere
weise auch noch im holzhaus haben wir
haben eine sprinkleranlage verbaut und
die konzeption haben wir uns aus dem u
boot bau abgeschaut es ist eine
hochdruck sprinkleranlage die mit 100
120 wasserdampf arbeitet und jede flamme
im keim erstickt brandschutz ist beim
holzbau natürlich großes thema
deswegen kommen verschiedene materialien
zum einsatz es entsteht ein sogenanntes
hybrid house außen aluminium und
inzwischen angekommen
stock des holz hochhauses
herr butter ich habe bisher noch nicht
den eindruck dass ich wirklich in einem
holzhaus pin ändert sich das jetzt noch
muss man den eindruck gleich ganz
dringend verändern wenn man hier nach
rechts in die musterwohnung gehen wenn
sie schon wahrnehmen dass wir sind ein
holzhaus befinden
wir befinden uns hier in einer
musterwohnung um die das wohnen mit holz
auch deutlich darzustellen wenn sie sich
an die decke schauen dann sehen sie auch
tatsächlich das konstruktions holz so
ist es auf die baustelle gekommen hat
hier noch eine rasur erfahren
und hier ist relativ viel holz verbaut
wenn der musterwohnung wollten wir auch
darstellen wie kompakt man boden kann
und welcher stauraum auch in einer
kleinen wohnung möglich ist und deswegen
sind hier zahlreiche einbaulösungen auch
realisiert worden
ja ist aber eine wohnung wie ist für
einen singlehaushalt konzipieren 39 eine
39 quadratmeter große wohnung für einen
singlehaushalt kompaktes boden zu
bezahlbaren preisen ist die überschrift
wir wollen breite schichten der
bevölkerung mit unseren wohnungen auch
ansprechen wir halten auch alles im
bestand und ist das denn jetzt das wohl
der zukunft also muss man sich als
bauherr darauf einstellen nur noch
kompakter einheiten zu produzieren wo
dann der single wohnen kann und es hängt
wahrscheinlich auch ein preis oder die
anzahl der haushalte steigt nimmt stetig
zu der flächenverbrauch pro person im
durchschnitt lich zu wir als unternehmen
als großer bestandshalter haben die
aufgabe kompakt zu bauen nachhaltigkeit
steht bei uns im vordergrund auch was
den flächenbedarf angeht und deswegen
ist es für uns eine herausforderung und
eine extrem wichtige frage der zukunft
kompakte bauweise zu realisieren um auch
eben bezahlbare preise anbieten zu
können ein gut durchmischtes quartier
geförderter wohnraum eigentums und
mietwohnungen ein ort für alle schichten
und altersklassen das war das ziel
investoren stadtplaner und architekten
schreiben konzepte und versuchen zu
gestalten
ob die bewohner wirklich gerne im neuen
stadt erleben können nur sie selbst
beschreiben also so könnte das leben in
der stadt der zukunft aussehen
ich stehe jetzt die neben einem bewohner
dieses staates warum sind sie denn auf
das buga gelände gezogen
es war mehr zufall dass es da natürlich
also wir haben eine wohnung gesucht
möglichst in die stadt rein zu kommen zu
einem guten preis und dass es dann
tatsächlich hier geklappt hat mit dem
epischen bundesgartenschau waren
natürlich dann optimal das ganze
quartier das ganze stadt hier ist ja
auch so konzipiert dass es möglichst
kurze wege nur bieten soll ist das
wirklich so das funktioniert tatsächlich
so ja also müssen wir schon sagen wir
sind zu fünft noten in die stadt
gelaufen zu fuß wir haben
einkaufsmöglichkeiten alle alles
lebensmittel alle konsumgüter eigentlich
die wir zu fuß erreichen können zum
kaufen zur arbeit brauche ich auch zu
fuß nur fünf minuten
also man hat es hier tatsächlich schon
sehr gut durchdacht sehr gut konzipiert
und da stimmt es dann auch tatsächlich
wenn der start mal sagt es ist eine
stadt der kurzen wege trifft tatsächlich
auch zu hat das auch irgendwie ihren
lebensstil dann ein bisschen gewandelt
also war das ein lerneffekt so dass sie
jetzt sagen jetzt benutzt das auto auch
möglichst wenig ich mache alles nur zu
fuß vom rad natürlich klar also ich hab
jetzt mittlerweile über mein arbeitgeber
fahrrad ließ ihn gemacht habe dann auch
wieder ein fahrer hatten vorher zwei
autos mittlerweile haben nur noch 1 wir
laufen sehr viel das auto geht
tatsächlich eigentlich nur mal für
großeinkäufe benutzt oder eben
wenn ein partner zur arbeit muss für
solche geschichten ist das auto stand
aber ansonsten laufen wir tatsächlich
sehr sehr viel was macht denn für sie
außer den kurzen wegen die wir jetzt
gesprochen haben was macht für sie
eigentlich das leben in so einer stadt
lebenswert es ist grundsätzlich das
leben in der stadt ist immer wichtig
dass es grünflächen gibt dass es
irgendwo auch eine möglichkeit gibt sich
zu erholen und das hat man hier auf dem
gelände jetzt tatsächlich auch dann
später nach der bundesgartenschau wenn
dann wieder gebaut wird hat man trotzdem
noch die grünflächen das was man hier
hinten raus sieht eben ist tatsächlich
auch was dann
das bleibt wir leben direkt am neckar
wir können uns trotzdem erholen wir
können es auf dem balkon setzen
rausgehen das denke ich so ein
hauptfaktor der tatsächlich wie ich also
für mich zumindest wichtig war einer
stadt zu leben dass man nicht nur
zwischen betonwänden wohnen sondern eben
auch orte hat um sich zu erholen
am anderen ende der welt wird die stadt
der zukunft anders geplant intelligente
gebäude intelligente transportsysteme
ein intelligentes gesundheitssystem
stichwort smart city inklusive totaler
vernetzung und hier soll der stadtteil
entstehen mitten in toronto kanadas
millionenmetropole direkt am wasser
bestes breitbandnetz autonomes fahren
apps für die mülltrennung alles möglich
alles denkbar
doch noch ist nichts davon zu sehen
außer ein paar skizzen dahintersteckt
sightwalk labs eine google tochter die
hier den ganz großen wurf plant aber
auch wenn du so eine nachbarschaft
kannst wirst du nie zu 100 prozent
zufrieden sein du musst immer
kompromisse eingehen
ein städte traum mit haken sagt sie
andrew keen sie ist datenschützerin und
professoren
[Musik]
wenn wir nicht aufpassen
entsteht hier ein stadtteil der all
deine persönlichen informationen sammelt
wo du wohnst wie viel müll du
produzierst ich meine lächerlich viele
persönliche daten von denen wir keine
ahnung haben was mit ihnen passiert denn
sämtliche abläufe in diesem stadtteil
basieren auf den daten der bewohner
jeder schritt wird er fast jedes
nachbarschaftsfest per app organisiert
toronto scheint dafür ein perfekter ort
zu sein ist eine der am schnellsten
wachsenden städte der welt
wir wollen hier wohnen noch mehr hier
arbeiten ein neues stadtviertel kommt da
wie gerufen
aber eines das total vernetzt ist und
seine bewohner überwacht privatsphäre
ist keine religion wenn du deine daten
preisgeben willst bitteschön so lange du
es bis der die entscheidungen trifft die
man sonst nicht die regierung nicht die
privatwirtschaft es musst deine
entscheidung sein
natürlich wolle man die privatsphäre der
anwohner schützen sagt uns die stadt auf
anfrage
wie genau sie das machen will lässt sie
aber offen fragen die sie bis zum bau
beginnen drei jahren wird klären müssen
ich bin hier mitten auf der b 39 oder
besser gesagt dass dem kleinen stückchen
was man davon übrig gelassen hat der
mann hat diesen streifen hier begrünt
für die bundesgartenschau und in einer
stadt der zukunft die man hier plant
will man jedem die möglichkeit geben
sein ziel verfehlt oder zu fuß zu
erreichen
denn in einer stadt der kurzen wege
braucht man eine bundesstraße nicht mehr
eine der wichtigsten fragen für eine
stadt der zukunft ist die frage nach dem
verkehr wie kann der effektiv geregelt
werden denn zurzeit gibt es da ja viele
schwierigkeiten
wir haben die diese problematik die
elektromobilität kommt nicht wirklich
voran
und bei den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
gibt es auch probleme viele verspätungen
sogar ausfälle
gesucht wird also das verkehrskonzept
der zukunft
[Musik]
es geht auch darum ganz klares
politisches zeichen zu setzen
zu sagen wir machen jetzt ernst wir
wollen die elektrobusse kaufen und die
hersteller das signal zu senden
es gibt einen markt und wenn ihr clever
seid lasst den mich an euch vorbei gehen
ergänzt durch sowas wie bike sharing und
carsharing da wo es halt auch da mit den
neuen verkehrsmittel nicht geht
[Musik]
so dass die fahrgäste nicht zu lange an
den bahnsteigen warten sondern wirklich
direkt umsteigen können
der deutschland pakt wird schon über
zehn jahre diskutiert und jetzt haben
wir im digitalen zeitalter die
möglichkeit das besser zu schalten und
wir werden den etappenweise einführen
[Musik]
alle belange die wir heute verkehrs
zeitig auf den weg bringen müssen eben
serono ziele haben was die sicherheit
angeht wenn das nicht gegeben ist werden
wir diese hehren ziele und auch
herausragenden technologischen
anforderungen nicht erfolgreich auf den
weg bringen
[Musik]
die stadt der zukunft gestalten wie kann
das gehen
für robert kaltenbrunner und peter
jakobowski spielt der verkehr eine große
rolle
der zustand heute abgaswolken lärm stau
zu viele probleme für die smart city von
morgen was sind die ganz konkreten
punkte in der stadt von heute was muss
ich dafür die zukunft ändern es gibt ja
dieses wunderbare schlagwort was aber
trägt von mir ángel städte für menschen
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt zum thema verkehr ist es einfach
so dass wir da sind wir uns auch und
fast die gesamte fachszene ein
eigentlich wenn wir städte für menschen
wieder gestalten wollen müssen von
überkommenen leitbild der autogerechten
stadt wegkommen das waren irrweg nicht
von anfang an aber diese dominanz über
jahrzehnte hat es eben zur situation in
der stadt kommen lassen wo man nur noch
quasi im suv sich wohlfühlt in der stadt
und keiner darüber nachdenkt was ist
eigentlich außerhalb dieser gefährte
das ist ein problem und wir glauben auch
oder ich glaube auch das ist ein
klimapolitisches argument natürlich
alternativen zum pkw zu finden
es ist aber auch eins was glaube ich
sehr viel lebensqualität schaffen kann
und die menschen wollen das glaube ich
auch wer in der stadt wohnt ist nicht so
wild darauf im auto zu fahren ich glaube
wenn die alternativen schaffen die
angebote verbessern und da komme
vielleicht auch noch mal drauf ist dass
ein einstieg der ganz wichtig ist weil
er viele themenfelder der stadt auch
anpackt lebensqualität das klima thema
hitze in linde gewinnen vielleicht
freiflächen für grün und andere
nutzungen also ganz wichtiger punkt aus
meiner sicht auch ist es denn ihrer
meinung nach so dass das auto weil es
stellplatz verbraucht werden im stau
steht etc einfach weg muss
beziehungsweise ist wesentlich weniger
auf jeden fall werden müssen um die
qualität im verkehr zurück zu gewinnen
oder ist beim stichwort smart city wäre
es auch möglich durch totale
vernetzungen alles so flüssig laufen zu
lassen dass man da auch besser
zurechtkommt in meinem letzten
und anzuknüpfen glaube ich dass eine
totale illusion ist dass wir ein
verkehrssystem hinbekommen wo autonom
fahrende bots nun dann gibt es
schlagwort mobilisierende mahnt die uns
also von jeder per app angegebenen
stelle abholen und dann zum ziel bringen
raushört dass das system ist was
funktionieren können irgendwelche das
kurz begründen
der öpnv auf das u bahnen s bahnen
straßenbahnen sind kann viel mehr
fahrgäste transportieren als es jemals
so ein bekannter sitzt ein zwei leute
denn die werden immer ein vielfaches an
flächenbedarf haben
das ist der erste punkt das heißt die
effizienz gerade in den großstädten
dieser brand systeme oder straßenbahn
system ist unerreicht das muss man
anders sei es ist teuer aber im
verkehrlichen ist es eine gigantische
leistung da wird man niemals von
wegkommen
man muss auch sagen dass diese autonom
fahrenden systeme zu einer extremen
erhöhung der fahrleistung führen werden
weil die fahren immer - zu einer nicht
mehr parken aber entweder fährt man sie
ja wie lucky luke sein pferd und wohin
und greift dann kommt es zurück aber es
wird nicht die ruhige beruhigte stadt
sein mit solchen system zudem bis wann
kann man sowas einführen heute ist das
auto in deutschland durchschnittlich
neun jahre alt ja ich glaube wir haben
40 millionen pkw die umschlagshäufigkeit
wird sich nicht drastisch erhöhen das
heißt bis man solche systeme
implementiert hat drei logisch sehen wir
da extrem große grenzen
und ich glaube man muss flankierend den
öffentlichen nahverkehr stärken also
zusammen und auch im image verbessern
länder wie die schweiz unmittelbar
benachbart oder hoch industrieland wie
japan haben eine kultur der hohen
akzeptanz von öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln
da fährt auch ein banker mit der
straßenbahn oder bauen
das ist und das ist bei uns scheinbar
und denkbar also ist auch fast eine
mediale aufgabe und es ist politisch
nudeln also die attraktivitätssteigerung
des psv als alternative mit dem spiel zu
bringen ist sozusagen das image des
voerder das hat sich enorm verbessert
gerade junge
integration und den möglichkeiten weil
sie mit dem dänischen las fahrrädern
sozusagen auf familien gerecht was zu
machen
aber man muss auch sehen dass sozusagen
unsere witterungsbedingungen oder auch
die großflächigkeit macher städte wie
berlin dem irgendwo auch grenzen setzen
also da wird neben fordert dessen fan
ich bin den öpnv brauchen es wird immer
auch irgendwie autos oder im wenn sie
autonom fahrende gefährte sind geben der
es muss eine zukunftsfähigere mix des
ganzen geben und damit die dominanz des
autos zurückgefahren werden es wäre
schon gut wenn der öpnv pünktlich käme
dann brauchte ich gar nicht so viele
apps um herauszufinden wie ich wenn der
bus oder die bahn nicht kommt wenn du
mama verkehrsmittel fahren könnte also
diese denke es möglicherweise auch
kompliziert um die ecke
also wenn er kommt alle sieben minuten
der preis stimmt werden glaube ich alle
deutlich zufriedener als zu tippen um
die nächste verspätung umgebung
irgendwie dann dann anzugeben sind beide
keine fans dieser festgefügten
zukunftsvisionen die gerne in bildern
transportiert werden mit flug taxis vor
grün bewachsenen hochhausfassaden wir
halten das für weit gehend interessen
geleitet von bestimmten gruppierung oder
ding und wir glauben dass es total sehr
viel banaler und verbesserung dessen
geht was eigentlich schon da ist und
dass das auch der weg in die zukunft
sein wird wir glauben aber das ist im
massenverkehr auch wenn es irgendwie
langweilig klingt nicht dass vieles von
dem was wir auch in den nächsten 40
jahren brauchen schon erfunden ist
vielleicht muss man es besser machen
komfortabler individuelle aber wir sehen
die großen brüche da nicht unbedingt
wenn sie mir noch eine bemerkung
gestatten wichtiges motiv für uns ganz
grundsätzlich war dass jeder auch teil
der stadt ist und das sind antworten
nicht in irgendwelchen groß systemen
liegen die von irgendjemand erfunden
werden von der politik oder industrie
und dann implementiert sondern jeder
auch durch sein verhalten dass seine
präferenzen dazu beiträgt wie die
zukunft sein wird und wir wollen auch
ein bisschen vorgehen es gibt auch so
eine heuchlerische komponente zb wird
betraut das ist kann
die tante emma läden mehr gibt aber das
eigene einkaufsverhalten zu sagen
unterstützt dass das gilt genauso bei
verkehrlichen belange also sozusagen
auch sich ein bisschen rechenschaft
darüber abzugeben was hat das für
wirkung auf stadt oder auf die
gemeinschaft insgesamt und was kann ich
bei mir selber irgendwie ändern damit
dass insgesamt besser flutscht und wie
wird in zukunft gebaut in welchen formen
mit welchen materialien ein altbekannter
rohstoff wird gerade wiederentdeckt 375
segmente aus furnierschichtholz bilden
diesen bionischen pavillon das vorbild
aus der natur zusammengefügt mit
modernster technik das ist jetzt ein
ziemlich futuristischer bau wie ich
finde nicht hat er jetzt im ersten
moment an bienen waren erinnert so von
der struktur her liege ich damit richtig
ja fast das ist die struktur eines
segels und ist zwar die verzahnung des
panzers aber übertragen in architektur
das ist unser musikpavillon okay das
heißt man nimmt sich aber die natur
wieder zum vorbild in bau ja es geht
darum die form intelligenz der natur zu
übernehmen und dadurch material zu
spannen absoluter leichtbau hier an
dieser stelle
ok leichtbau es klingt jetzt auch nach
dem technischen ziemlichen aufwand sowie
das so zusammengestellt ist ja und zwar
sind hier mehrere roboter tätig die
zusammen diese kassetten bauen weil die
über 300 kassetten die sind alle
unterschiedlich gefertigt das gibt ein
zimmermann heute nicht mehr hin dass die
computer übernehmen diese form
intelligenz aus der natur
das hat zur folge dass wir mit möglichst
wenig ressourcen hier bauen können jetzt
ist mir bei der bundesgartenschau sofort
klar wofür das gebäude da ist wenn eine
bühne sind die musikveranstaltung die
oder ich kann mich mal ausruhen wenn es
wieder 30 grad sind habe ich ihren
schönen schattenplatz aber wofür ist
dieses gebäude genau errichtet worden
was der zweck wenn die bundesgartenschau
mal vorbei ist dass grundlagenforschung
für die besucher erst mal erlebbares
neues bauen man sagt ihr europäisches
bauen aber in zukunft könnten solche
gebäude auch dazu dienen die stadt
aufzustocken konkret ist die idee aus so
einer konstruktion ein parkhaus
innenstadt anlage mit einem zusätzlichen
kuppel als zusätzliche ebene hierzu
starten ist dann die robotik so die
beste möglichkeit um auch in der stadt
immer wieder mal nach zu verdichten
glaube ich nennt man das also sprich
immer mal wieder nochmal ein stockwerk
irgendwo drauf setzen zu können er die
robotik hat den vorteil dass man diese
natürlichen konstruktion nachbauen kann
in architektur übersetzen die idee ist
aber auch die fabrikation auf die
baustelle zu bekommen dass die roboter
hier sind zwei roboter im verbund
unterwegs gewesen dann auf der baustelle
auch dieses gebäude hier erstellen
roboter brauchten die architekten auch
für den bau des carbon pagojus er soll
leicht und gleichzeitig stabil sein glas
und kohlefasern werden miteinander
verwebt der pavillon wird programmiert
und auf dem gelände nur noch montiert
wenn das architektonisch jetzt die
zukunft ist weiß ich gar nicht wie ich
mich damit fühlen soll weil ein bisschen
erinnert ja schon eine spinne ist es
auch wieder der natur nachempfunden
diese konstruktion
also es geht hier um den vater bau in
der natur und zwar der käfer flügels
elektronenmikroskopische untersucht
worden und der lauf der fas dann ist
auch eine art statisches gerüst und hier
in architektur in dem sie den glasfaser
und kohlefaser wie auf einem webstuhl
nachempfunden ich bin ja schon sehr
flexibel ich kann holz sägen wie ich
würde ja gerne aber hier mit den fasern
hast dass ich kann das zeug wirklich
jede form bringen die ich will das was
ein baby wohl sozusagen spannen kann das
sind der gespannte konstruktion
da gibt es auf teller förmige
letztendlich wo der webstuhl sozusagen
im kreis unterwegs ist dann entweder
nicht solche haben
und hier sind wir mehr diese linearen
knappen die dann zusammen dann ein
zentral charakteren von der ferne aus
betrachtet eben als hierhin kam dachte
ich das ding muss doch tonnen wiegen
dann sind wir ein bisschen näher
herangekommen und dann habe ich mir das
ganze auch mal aus der nähe angeguckt
und er ist wieder ist es genau umgekehrt
nicht dass ich könnte das ding so
durchschnitten ja womit liege ich denn
jetzt falsch
also sie haben jetzt hier die glasfaser
angefasst das sozusagen die unterlage
aber oben wird die kohlefaser
aufgelegten sehr leistungsfähiges
material und sollen abschnitt wird etwa
60 bis 80 kilo hat aber eine bruch last
von 25 tonnen
das heißt also ein material mit wenig
rohstoff eine hohe traglast in der
architektur ok klingt nach einem großen
vorteil was genau kann ich damit machen
also die idee ist nach diesem
ausstellungspavillon der auch an die
bauartbedingte zulassung benötigt hat
konkret in architektur anwendungen zu
gehen in dem sinne fassaden leichter zu
bauen die vorher vielleicht aus stahl
gefertigt sind hier die kohlefaser die
glasfaser ist arg material einzusetzen
das leben in der stadt wird auch immer
teurer und wenn man an die zukunft des
bauens und wohnens denkt darf man die
provinz nicht aus den augen verlieren
denn auf dem land haben die architekten
noch platz und können sich richtig
austoben
blaibach oberpfalz ein meteorit ist
gelandet
brennan ertönt galati
das waren total ungewöhnliches projekt
am anfang hat man gesagt da kommt zum
fitzcarraldo spinne und der willigen ein
opernhaus bauen ja und inzwischen glaube
ich haben wir wir haben vielleicht mal
gefühlte 90 prozent dagegen jetzt aber
gefühlte 90 prozent dafür
ein konzerthaus thomas bauer der sänger
und peter haimerl ein architekt beide
aus der region wollten das dorf und
seinen ruinösen ortskern beleben
hochkultur stadt dorfgemeinschaftshaus
initiator bauer hat selbst mit gehämmert
und anfangs neben kommunaler
unterstützung und sponsorengeldern sogar
privat gebürgt es wurde ein erfolg
auch überregional seitdem lebt das dorf
wieder eine eindeutige prognose können
sie am ende nicht geben und ob das dann
konzerthaus ist oder eine galerie oder
etwas anderes was irgendwie mit kunst zu
tun hat man muss mit herzblut dahinter
sein muss was riskieren auch er hatte
etwas riskiert bürgermeister thomas
brandt plante die zukunft in der
prignitz brandenburg 16 ferienwohnungen
aus einem verlassenen plattenbau alles
wieder natur die natur holt sich darf
alles zurück leerstand wie in vielen
ländlichen regionen auch in der prignitz
wer hier geblieben ist richtet sich
einen auch ohne becker bank und bus es
gibt kaum arbeit
seit der einheit ist knapp jeder vierte
weg vor allem die jüngeren fehlen
bürgermeister brandt hatte vor jahren
die idee leerstehende drei raum
wohnungen in der platte aufzumöbeln neue
fensterbilder frisch renoviert gut 70
quadratmeter eigentum im grünen für
20.000 euro doch es fand sich niemand
still stand seit sechs jahren
nun droht auch hier der abriss wie
nebenan für ihn ist klar es auf dem land
fehlt die grundversorgung den
vorsorgeheft in meinen augen als er
bürgermeister dass der staat
verpflichtet ist bestimmte grund lässt
unter science versorgung aufrecht zu
erhalten dazu gehört die fünf jahre
öffentlicher personennahverkehr gehören
vernünftige dienstleistungen vor ort für
die bürger dass man eben auch eine
gewisse lebensqualität hat und sich
nicht abgehängt führt und als bürger
zweiter klasse behandelt
weiter östlich die uckermark architekt
thomas krüger verwandelt hier leer
stehende scheunen ställe und gehöfte in
architektonische perlen für städter und
urlauber durchblicke ausblicke licht
design und materialien im einklang mit
der natur
schöner wohnen für die die auf busse
bahnen und hat er immer leben weniger
angewiesen sind im moment die potenz aus
der stadt die kommt die diese
ortschaften aufrechterhält ansonsten
würden die raucht großteil leer stehen
es ist eine chance für die orte die sich
entleeren weil es einfach ökonomisch
ansonsten kaum möglichkeiten gibt im
österreichischen vorarlberg haben sie
schon vor jahren damit begonnen
abwanderung zu verhindern attraktivität
zu bewahren
mit originellen ideen erfolgreich dies
ist eine bushaltestelle
wenn auch ohne dach arnold hinspiel war
bürgermeister seine mission im
alltäglichen das besondere entdecken
ungewöhnliche lösungen für alle im ort
es kommen wegen dieser bus halte sind
wir sicher sehr viele besucher nach
krombach und schauen sich diese zweite
verrückt
ein hoch auf den öffentlichen nahverkehr
sieben internationale architekten von
japan des schiele schufen kunstwerke des
wartens eine initiative lokaler
architekten bezahlt mit sponsorengeldern
mobilität ist entscheidend lange warten
muss man hier allerdings nicht das
netzwerk der land busse ist vorbildlich
im dorf geht man die herausforderungen
gemeinsam an zukunftsorientiert das
jahrzehntelange dogma des eigenheims ist
in krombach linkspartei wissen
selbstverständlich geworden das
einfamilienhaus ist eigentlich bei uns
eine seltenheit geworden seit 15 jahren
machen wir auch keine aktive
bodenpolitik hat keine organisation für
bauplätze vereinsamen
das haben wir auch aufgehört und ersetzt
durch die mobilisierung von baugrund für
mehr wohnhäuser krumbach setzt jetzt auf
gemeinschaftliches wohnen mieter und
eigentümer verschiedene generationen
unter einem dach der bürgermeister wohnt
inzwischen auch hier
wir wissen den vorarlbergern wir so
weiter machen das in 300 jahren
sämtliche bebaubare grund verbaut würde
es ist völlig unverantwortlich wir
müssen reagieren es ist ein gebot der
stunde
das ist ganz in seinem sinne hat michael
ii ein architekt und städtebauer für den
stadt und land entwicklung nicht
getrennt zu sehen sind sparen und 08 15
bauten haben keine zukunft im ländlichen
raum ist die gestaltungsmöglichkeit sehr
viel größer als in den städten wo sehr
viele schon standardisiert ist und das
müssen wir sinnvoll nutzen und nicht
diese standardisierungs konzepte auf den
ländlichen raum übertragen
mutig auf lokale kräfte materialien und
ökologie setzen
das will man auch oft dieser brache am
nordhessischen edersee früher mal ein
bauernhof mit campingplatz
nun entsteht hier das projekt ways of
life des korbacher architekten christoph
hesse visionäre entwürfe internationaler
architekten fürs wohnen 4.0 energie
autark digital vernetzt
keines dieser häuser teurer als 250.000
euro wir denken wir können unseren
beitrag dazu leisten dass gerade junge
leute die gut ausgebildet sind nicht
unbedingt in die städte gehen müssen um
dort dann aktiv werden zu können um dort
ihren leben zum teil zu verdienen es ist
viel möglich dass verheißen wir in dem
ja die die industrie 4.0 bietet halt
wirklich viele chancen
es gibt sie die ideen für die provinz
wie gut denn wo sollen all jene hin
denen in der stadt die luft oder das
geld ausgeht
es braucht nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als gutes internet kreativität
politischen willen und lokale
überzeugungstäter
[Musik]
wie also wird unsere welt in zukunft
aussehen wie leben wir arbeiten die das
essen und das trinken wir viele fragen
wir werden weiter versuchen sie zu
beantworten
auf unserem weg in die zukunft 20 47
würde ich sagen da war ich noch nicht
flugs komplett ran
[Musik]